so we we we talked a bit about law
enforcement
fbi going after uh you james but i'm
interested to hear from you andy you're
dealing with it with a different kind of
bad guy you're dealing with
extremist organizations that are really
angry you've been exposing a lot of
their people and their their uh violent
ground work we can call it not only are
you dealing with these people making up
lies about you posting constantly but
physically attacking you and threatening
you so i'm interested in in this
perspective your take on journalism you
know we've heard from james on the
institutional powers but what's
happening with groups like antifa and
these other far left extremists
targeting you
i well one crucially what makes them
particularly empowered is that
they're
the narratives that they are able to
spread in the mainstream press uh
haven't really been challenged um
you see it every day so
um
the various riots that happened
after trump were elected were
treated essentially
peaceful protests of people reacting in
anger against his his election win
rather than rather than as people who
were
rejecting and using violence to voice
their opposition to a
uh
the electoral process you're saying that
there was an insurrection among the far
left in dc where they smashed windows
and set limousines on fire and were
attacking people
yeah so the language matters right yeah
language really matters what what pay
attention to what is described as a
peaceful protest mostly peaceful process
versus
uh insurrection right like they the it's
not the differences are uh
that contrast is intentional
and um
antifa rely on allies in the press
because obviously what they do is would
be unpalatable for the majority of the
public if the public was accurately
informed this you know those wanton acts
of arson
maiming and injuries of other people
killing people carrying out terrorist
attacks such as attacks on government
buildings government facilities police
stations uh trying to derail
uh trains they actually did derail train
didn't they yeah there were two
convictions last year in washington
state and that claim
where's the i'm sorry i started but
where is cnn headline breaking new york
times front page far left extremist
derail train i mean that didn't happen
they didn't they didn't talk about it it
was an attempted derailing attempt to
derail derailing but which you know the
charges was under uh the anti-terrorism
statutes in the federal law so there
were two young women the claim of
responsibility was posted on this
far-left extremist group site called
it's going down which was banned by
facebook by the way last year still
operates openly
on twitter
a trump supporter could fart in dc and
it becomes a headline story
extremists attempt to derail a train
what were they doing they're pouring
concrete or something like that i don't
get into too much detail but they were
trying to sabotage train tracks which
can cause not only excessive you know
property damage but could kill people
that's that's the craziest thing about
it uh that that is an attempt to kill
and the the amount of damage from
derailing these trains as much as many
people on the left don't like to get
into the economics of it it could cause
people great suffering in terms of not
being able to eat there are poor people
who rely on food coming in and resources
from from local governments to help them
this level of disruption could have
literally killed people directly
involved in the train and then have
massive repercussions for the poor and
the suffering in these cities no news
coverage where is it where's the where's
the big story where's the national
conversation where's where's cnn to go
out and be like this is isn't is insane
these conversations it doesn't happen
yeah well the point you're making is
sometimes
by not reporting you are reinforcing a
particular narrative and that's what
happens and there are so few people uh
who are focused on the antifa beat that
it makes
uh the number the few of us who do it
really subjected to
actual violence continue to violence and
threats of violence against our family
and
if you happen to live in a city that i
lived in portland oregon where in my
view the the rule of law is compromise
police departments don't have the
resources to respond and the local
government is so corrupt that they
express support for these extremists
then you have to essentially a sort of a
approval from why do you think state
actors why do you think that other
people that other outlets and other
journalists don't want to cover these
guys
uh because a few journalists who have
who are from establishment press uh
experience what it's like to be suddenly
targeted online so you think it's a fear
thing yes they don't want to do it
because they're afraid yeah it's also
the ideological thing i think for lack
of a better word communism communists
don't want to breach discipline for to
do so would be an act of blasphemy like
when jake tapper takes his tweet down
that's crazy that is how do you do that
where's the principle i tweet stupid
things all the time and get mocked where
i just leave them up i don't care right
like i i'll delete something if i tweet
it right away there's a typo or like a
word is it's not phrased properly but i
get people being like how your tweets
are and i'm like i don't know whatever i
said it you know they they have this is
the challenge of our brave new world
that they
will inflict almost any type of
injustice for their cause it defies
reason it defies logic
they'll influence and and i have i have
respect i mean this in kind of a dark
way i have so much respect for them i
see it the christian i just get
interviewed as a christian magazine
earlier today and they wanted advice i'm
like grow a pair of balls
you guys love going to church but beyond
praying what the hell are you doing
the communists have faith and it's a
faith that they live or die by they want
to give up their lives well there's
their cause are they really who
i mean they're willing to burn down
buildings they're willing to burn down
buildings buildings but they're not
willing to give up their lives some of
them i love them no we've seen look
we've seen them
giving up their lives maybe it wouldn't
be incarcerated i mean history yeah but
i mean
i'm talking about recently so i mean if
we look at for example
um protests at the capitol for example i
was talking to an attorney marina madven
who represents you guys probably know
who she is represents some january 6th
protesters or writers whatever you want
to say and um there's this rabbi who
she's representing who is being charged
with parading and it's a misdemeanor
and her argument um he's you know
they're trying to sentence him to all
this long prison term well longer than
necessary like six i don't know some
days prison term um and her argument is
that people who were arrested for
protesting in the capital against brett
kavanaugh got a fifty dollar fine yeah
so why is this rabbi getting like
an excessive sentence an excessive fine
when he was in there for less time for
like five minutes and left because it's
a cult
it's obvious that the machine is slanted
in one direction right we've all said in
a variety of ways the institutions are
protecting one side and demonizing the
other right but
in terms of that protester right got
charged with 50 dollars she knows she's
not going to have to give up her that's
that's that's not that's not that she
knows
the leftists know that they have legal
resources behind them the right doesn't
have that right they have the national
lawyers guild behind them so they don't
they're giving true yes that's not true
they're giving trainings on what to do
they're willing to do this they're
willing to sacrifice each other they're
willing to a certain degree to sacrifice
themselves now many of them may not
think they're going to lose their lives
completely but they entered these
positions i've been to these meetings
luke and i were at a big a big meeting
in france and they say to everyone
outright you could end up in prison for
the rest of your lives in charge of
terrorism and they say they say okay so
when i see a dude working at taco bell
and he's got a black lives matter mask
and his manager says take the mask off
because the black lives matter thing get
a new one or you're fired and he says
then fire me the far left screams they
make demands and taco bell backs down
and says we're sorry the right does
nothing they do nothing it's the
revolutionary heart of communism i think
it's the power to to act upon their
convictions and i think history is
replete with accounts of this
whitaker chambers wrote about it douglas
hyde wrote about it he converted from
uh communism to catholicism there's
there's a lot of examples of people it's
it's at the heart of their for lack of a
better word religion
and i think they're willing to act upon
their ideals and from my perspective i
think we can learn from their faith
to act not break the law
but
not worry about being shamed
in some regards the modern day
equivalent of giving up your your lively
life livelihood you're giving up your
livelihood yeah we and your reputation
yeah and your and your accounts they
don't care we had darren beating for
speaking out we had darren they're not
afraid they're not afraid
darren beatty said he thinks that the
right and i'm probably i'm paraphrasing
but i think the general idea was the
right is actually more prone to cancel
culture than the left because the right
has more people scared of the mainstream
opinion against them so they're willing
to tell people who are either to the
right of center or you know or more
conservative traditionally conservative
they're not going to defend them and you
see this in congress even marjorie
taylor green gets condemned and booted
off her her committee assignments
because the republican party panics
meanwhile ilhan omar can say whatever
she wants
yeah and then donald trump just wants to
be liked by the new york times yeah and
wants to be liked by the corporate
institutions and that kind of train of
thinking you know it's not going to
there are republicans who care more
about the opinion of the new york times
and the opinion of their own
constitution that is exactly the point
and until they stop caring
they can't be effective and it and it
comes down to the faith i've been saying
this for years and i don't know how else
to say it sounds like a cliche but the
moment the republican party stops being
humili they you give them that power
we give them that power that's not a
power they have
it's only a power if you give it to them
yeah the moment you stop caring and you
stop giving them then you're free to
actually do but but they won't because a
lot of the people in the republican
party aren't there for the right reasons
you want to know why they don't like you
james because you change the news cycle
how is the news cycle set the new york
times cnn these big companies decide
there's a big story and then people in
politics try and jump on it to address
the issue and i wonder that sometimes
i'm like how is it that the new york
times just decides to run a headline
story and all of a sudden that's what
we're talking about but something
interesting happens with veritas you
report a story and it trends number one
on twitter all of a sudden they're
forced to address it and they don't like
doing that
i want to get even deeper on you this is
a daily beast headline
by lloyd grove and they tried to do this
shame crap with me they tried to get me
to i'm so sorry i apologize i shouldn't
have done and the headline reads
it's impossible to shame james o'keefe
that's a badge of honor right there do
you understand we should frame this and
put it in our bathroom at headquarters
do you understand do you understand now
how the game is played the whole point
the whole point
is to shame you when they couldn't when
their modus operandi
and here's what's scary when they
couldn't shame you the fbi shows up when
they couldn't shame andy they found him
in the street they beat him up well
they're running out of arrows aren't
they because how do you exceed you know
how aggressive it is for a for the fbi
to execute a search warrant against an
american journalist the attorney general
of the united states expressly forbids
it in a memo by merrick garland in july
you do not execute search warrants
against journalists particularly for
this issue they probably broke the law
and that doesn't that show kind of a bit
of desperation yeah absolutely i i
wonder if
there's something else we don't know yet
the fbi maybe got worried that you had a
whistleblower with some information and
the only way they could figure out what
stories you were working on was to drum
up some fake search warrant to get
access to your doctor well the problem
with that strategy is that most of my
employees
i'm the ceo of the company i i do some
reporting but not all
most of our employees are the ones with
sources
and they didn't take their phones
well they don't know what to do i think
i think they're panicked they're
desperate we can see it with like like
you mentioned libby how they're going
after these january 6 guys with extreme
uh charges relative to what the left has
done and we had an insurrection in 2017
luke and i were there on the ground we
saw conspiracy charges against all of
these you know black-clad individuals
who are smashing windows setting fires
and most of them just got let go that's
right they couldn't hold any charges
against them well and that goes on in so
many of these cities that are democrat
run and they've just taken that strategy
and they're using it all over the place
gascon and the da in la does this catch
and release thing
that's not working the the new d.a in
new york has promised to do something
very similar uh it's going to make the
city that is crumbling even worse in new
york just really quickly in new york
there was activists being arrested for
eating without a vax pass eating without
permission from the government when a
woman was murdered yards away from them
so the police is is prioritizing vaccine
domestic passports over literal murders
that happened this is happening under
the eric adams administration that
promised campaigned to be tough on crime
and this is happening in the city right
now it's absolutely ridiculous well they
also promised to be uh tough on vaccine
mandates and they've continued that as
well
to the extent where people are literally
being thrown in front of trains and
they're not
uh that's actually not new in the city
although it is horrifying the crime is
up there's crime is up yeah yeah no it's
a disaster it's a disaster for sure we
have so interesting andy and i were
talking about this earlier that um so
many of these cities that our democrat
run
what was our conversation
but we were talking about that but by
mid mid december there were dozens of
cities in america that had surpassed
its historical record on homicides and
murders portland being one of them uh
and there were 11 others this was just
mid-december i'm not sure if they were
by then you know the end of 2021 if
there were more than that um
it's a direct consequence
uh that will be felt for years and years
of the um
the political and social changes in our
culture after george floyd died that was
right and it's like social justice uh
social justice initiatives are not going
to make cities safer it turns out it's
just going to make it worse for the very
people that you're claiming to try and
protect but i wonder if that's you know
these people aren't trying to protect
anybody
we see well they're trying to protect
themselves and the people who read the
new york times i think it's worth trying
to protect criminals i i think it's
worse than that it's it's the chaos that
destroys the system that allows them to
exploit it they're letting people out of
prisons because it creates crime they're
doing these they're setting forth these
policies that are making everyone's
lives genuinely worse and more chaotic
then as everything gets crazy they come
out and say we're the solution give us
the power they they they enact policies
that destroy the system and then tell
you they're the only solution yes they
do do that
uh and then they enact further policies
that continue to destroy things yes i
think they do do that is another good
way to say it too because these policies
are utter crap
they don't make sense
they come out and often by decree yes
they're pushing these policies and of
course we've had we've had nothing but
rule by decree for the past two years
right these executive orders have got to
stop the the emergency powers that have
been given
to governors and mayors have got to end
the people need their representation in
new york city we're being mandated
without representation at this point you
know it's like some stamp act [ __ ]
is what we've got going on they're
mandating you guys get three vaxes an
hour is it still two it's still the two
but you know but cases are through the
roof anyway and there's room on those
vax cards for a whole bunch of more crap
that they can inject us with that's what
the conspiracy theorists were saying
like why is there
why are there five yeah
lines here this doesn't make any sense
and and the conspiracy theorists are
saying it's not just going to be two
it's going to be a lot more and you know
i keep getting into arguments with
people too about whether or not my child
should be vaccinated and i'm like he's
been exposed to covid 500 million times
he's tested negative 500 million times
he was around me when i got covered he
was around his dad when his dad got
covered he keeps being fine like if he's
fine what do we what do we need this for
so many kids are fine they're men
they're requiring five-year-olds not
only be vaccinated but also wear a face
mask just to go to you know like
whatever the
olive garden in times square which i
don't know why anyone wants to go there
but still anywhere to go to
i have a question have any of the
politicians or activists who
demanded
uh that police be defunded
apologize that their
project
resulted in historical numbers of black
and brown people and vulnerable people
dying in urban areas they just ignore
that that fact
they ignore it there i mean we saw that
video where the two antifa women are
vandalizing the property and two young
black women say why are you doing this
get out of here we don't want this look
we're doing it to help you we're helping
you it's like no you're not
you're destroying our community yeah
yeah i i'll tell you that story when i
was in ferguson when the young black man
black men linked arms to defend the the
liquor store where michael brown had
bought the uh the cigars had stolen the
cigarillos and they were interviewed by
al jazeera and they said these people
looting and raiding our stores don't
live here man
but you know what we end up seeing
from i think it was the new republic i
can't remember which outlet it was so
forgive me if it wasn't but uh in
defense of looting
as people who live in the community were
begging for the violence to stop and
outside forces were exploiting it and
burning down their buildings
prominent left-wing activist media said
it was a good thing yeah they were they
were it was it was revolution and i'm
like the people who live there aren't
doing this i'm glad you brought that
brought that up npr did a very glowing
interview with the author of that book
vicki osterwell yes that's correct
and this is why narrative is important
because
when the mainstream left
essentially
puts out this
um
is platforming people
who are arguing in support of violent
extremism in criminality
that shifts the whole overton window and
i think we've seen that very clear we've
seen that slowly in the last six years
in the opinion section of the new york
times i mean they publish some really
awful things like uh
i'm still disturbed by that one piece of
the the parent asking if his uh black
child should have white friends yeah
that was really upsetting that was the
charles blow story i think wasn't it uh
i don't know
so um
yeah that that shifts and uh we've seen
you know what as all that violence was
happening in 2020 where where it wasn't
just property destruction we had 20 at
least 26 people who died as a result and
there were peripheral deaths too so
there were there were some instances
where people died indirectly as a result
of the riots like rose roads being
closed uh ambulances being blocked
things like that and then you had the
overt murders people like david dorn who
were just just killed in these riots
reporting that i will always give a
shout out to michael tracy where he
actually drove to these small towns
it was it was icao and yanka sorry it
was what for what that was the author
yeah author of it i had it wrong oh okay
can my children be friends with white
michael tracy went he drove across the
country and went to these very small
towns and he saw boarded up windows
spray paint saying please don't hurt us
things like that oh
i saw myself uh in so i was in the
capitol hill autonomous zone chazz in in
seattle this is where
blm far left extremists and antifa took
over
six blocks of a major american city
created a hard border and had people
with guns guarding these
checkpoints it was allowed to go on
three weeks people died there on the
wind and this was a really heavily
densely populated area the businesses on
there had signs that said black owned
business asian or business person of
color owned business as sort of these i
mean it seems really kind of like
medieval right it's like please please
don't harm us because every inch of that
entire six boxes vandalized
um
i have to wonder you know uh we often
talk about civil war or civil unrest or
or whatever
fun uh in in i guess a funny twist or
whatever or everyone describe it when
luke was reading about post-pandemic
civil unrest is when we got swatted so
i'm i'm curious luke if we never
actually i don't think i got to flesh
out what was going on with that as we're
looking at what happened with chas and
with minnesota and with all this stuff
i think there's a real possibility that
not only was it were we already likely
to see civil unrest because of the
pandemic lockdowns but you add to this
the fact that black lives matter
rhetoric and writing over the past few
years has never been checked it has
never been held to account
i think that's going to lead to
something you know substantial
especially when you consider the
economic factors that are also adding a
lot of stress to the entire system with
people finding it harder and harder just
to find commonly household used items
the the store shelves are also being
emptied not just because of the winter
storm but because of the global supply
chain shortages and the problems that
have started that we still haven't felt
the full effects of so when you combine
all of that and the historical pretext
for unrest when it comes to pandemics
this is a recipe for disaster especially
at the state that the united states is
in right now with what people are
calling a decline of an empire there's a
lot of things coming together all at
once but it's it's a storm that's
absolutely uh dangerous to be in the blm
riots and the anti-foreign it wasn't
that they were only unchecked they were
encouraged and they were encouraged
those rioters were encouraged to flout
coveted restrictions so i remember in
june 2020 just a real quick interjection
actually it was um one article said that
they actually reduced the spread of
covenant yes no joke no joke they
reported that well andrew cuomo said um
and bill de blasio said that if uh
contract tracers spoke to people who had
been protesting for social justice they
were not to ask them if they had been
you know not to ask people have you been
doing this in order to help the contract
tracing but it was in june of 2020 that
there was a
10 000 person protest outside of the
brooklyn museum of art
in well in brooklyn
ten thousand people out protesting to
end violence against black trans people
and this was the mayor said this was
more important than coveted restrictions
and it was it was literally at that
moment like i was already sort of done
with this pandemic in may i can't you
know whatever and then at that moment i
was like and everything you have said
and everything you are now going to say
is a complete and total fabrication
it's fully a lie as soon as there's 10
000 people allowed to hang out outside
the brooklyn museum and protest uh you
know supporting black trans lives and me
and my kid can't go to the movies and we
can't go to the met and we can't do
anything everything you are you were
thoroughly discredited 100 discredited
the government entirely
in new york state and in the city i
think i remember watching de blasio on
the corporate media i think it was cnn
announcing shyster yeah announcing hey
we're gonna restrict this you can't go
to the movies you can't go to the
supermarket you can't eat at restaurants
you can't do this this and then this and
then he was asked what about the protest
he's like oh they're justified
a bunch of these same stupid doctors and
researchers and scientists who wrote the
rogan letter who penned that letter
saying that racial justice protests are
reasonable reason to not adhere to
covert restrictions you mean the
dentists and nursing students
and the cannabis farmer
yeah i gotta respect the guy who's
farming cannabis but i don't think he
should be
he's not a doctor
non-board certified
people yeah
back alley veterinarians
i don't like what joe rogan's talking
about the veterinary abortionists oh man
sorry
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time